rich panelists who is Charlie Cobb
charlie is the president of the
committee for economic development and
I'm also proud to say he's a member of
the advisory board of the Mazon file
says as our two of our other panelists
Adam Gopnik and on tone and boldly and
the committee for Economic Development
is a business-led public policy
organization in Washington DC that is
dedicated to conducting policy research
and making policy recommendations on
major social and economic issues it was
founded in 1942 and his weight in and
had an influence on such things as the
marshall plan on education reform camp
mind if I campaign finance reform and
most more recently on health care reform
in the US the CED published in 2006 a
report entitled education for global
leadership the importance of
International Studies and foreign
language education for US economic and
national security that is among its most
frequently downloaded reports and
Charlie's been asked to speak on this
issue for a number of different
audiences around the country I think
that tonight he wants to take a slightly
different tack perhaps a more lyrical
approach than the one that he shares in
his report but we can come back to talk
about the report's recommendations and
findings perhaps in the QA I just wanted
to add that it's really important to
have a group like the CED weighing in as
a business voice on issues such as early
education they published a very
important report arguing in favor of
universal early education in the United
States and when siiii when the CED
speaks Washington listens so it's very
important in addition to his many in
addition to his many other
accomplishments Charlie holds degrees
from Princeton oxford university and the
university of virginia where he earned
his law degree and his career has
included a number of important
government positions including deputy
assistant to the president for domestic
policy at the White House under the
first president Bush and he is also an
unabashed francophile and a fluent
French speaker
and I think we'll hear a little bit from
Charlie about his exposure to France and
what that has meant to him
professionally professionally and
personally Charlie shanny thank you
thank you very much and thanks to to all
of you for for coming I am really
honored to be on this panel tonight and
also to serve on the board of the maze
nicole says at Columbia University and
shanny i also want to salute your
outstanding leadership first a little
background about the committee for
Economic Development chandi gave you
some of it we are a nonpartisan
bipartisan business-led think tank
founded in 1942 we did the design plan
for what ultimately became the marshall
plan and our founding trustee Studebaker
CEO Paul Hoffman was chosen by President
Truman to be the first administrator of
the Marshall Plan we work on economic
policy issues that promote economic
growth at home and abroad and our
trustees number some 200 senior
corporate executives and university
presidents including i'm pleased to say
columbia President Lee Bollinger in
recent years our work has included
fiscal reform health care reform
education policy at all stages early
education where we've actually learned a
great deal from from France k12 and now
higher education we work on trade policy
corporate governance and money in
politics we were the business group a
few years ago that worked very closely
with senators John McCain and russ
feingold on important campaign finance
reform legislation about five years ago
we issued the report that that Jenny
mentioned I have one copy here which I
lockshin off later that's on our website
and did you hand out copper do we have
copies of the judge summary the two-page
summary on the desk up and until we
released our health care report in 2009
the study that we did on foreign
languages with CDs most downloaded
report now this ced report of this
project was initially my idea but i had
to actually exercise extreme restraint
and objectivity to avoid plugging any
one particular foreign languages
the one that I speak French so what what
we said in our report is that we need
more young people in this country who
have greater knowledge about the rest of
the world and to have solid proficiency
in at least one additional language
knowing a foreign language though is not
just a matter of Education it relates to
our Economic Security our national
security and the effectiveness of our
public diplomacy business leaders will
tell you that having international
experience and foreign language
competency are critical to their
operations but why French in doing some
research for this evening I found that
in 1782 the Berlin Academy sponsored an
essay contest based on the following
question how his French become the
world's universal language there were 22
entrance and two first prizes were
awarded one to a Frenchman Antoine de
leyva hall a protege of Voltaire and
another the second to Jean Christ Schwab
a German professor at the Academy of
Stuttgart it was leave a hole who argued
that French had acquired its global
status because of its clarity simplicity
and conciseness especially when it came
to conducting business he wrote he wrote
that zucchini pal Claire nipponsei if
it's not clear it's not French much has
changed though since 1782 and English
has now overtaken French as the global
language now there are lots of facts and
figures about French slipping into I
don't know eighth ninth tenth whatever
place it is in terms of the number of
speakers worldwide and Sunni Albanese
decision to close its major minor and
graduate programs in French Italian
Russian German and the classics strikes
me as both the pourable and something
that should be promptly reversed and I
want to salute as i did upstairs your
your leadership and your courage in
speaking out on on this topic it's very
important and thank you so that the
details the facts the figures on this
debate are interesting they're very
important but that's not where I'm going
to go this evening tonight's topic you
is why French matters and before I
really launch into what I have to say
perhaps I should warn you that i have
been trained both as a litigator and in
oxford university's peculiar and very
unfriend of linguistic analytical
philosophy so when confronted with a
question you never answer it you ask you
ask what it means and then you analyze
its meaning to death answering the
question directly would of course be to
continental to french and one just
doesn't do that in England you first
question the question then you take it
apart except that shany cleverly avoided
asking a question the topic isn't
according to the bold headline it isn't
why does French matter it is instead a
bold assertion French matters and we're
here tonight to explain why for me the
issue is relatively simple and
straightforward French matters because
France matters it matters to me it
matters to each of us in this room and
it matters to the world and the reason
France matters is not just tied to
quantitative measures such as gross
domestic product its trade balance the
size of its population the strength at
its military its role within the EU or
even the number of people around the
world who speak French so in offering
this perspective on why French and
France matter I'd like to suggest four
points points that rely less on logic
and linguistic analysis and somewhat
more on my own lyrical impressions and I
hope you will find them both confusing
at first and worthwhile so here are the
four points number one what goes around
keeps going around number two life is
about beauty number three Americans
really want to be French
and finally in France they dance point
number one what goes around keeps going
around long before the United States had
its so-called special relationship with
England we were enemies with the British
France by contrast was there with us at
the beginning along with Morocco in the
free city of ragusa which is now known
as Dubrovnik France was one of the first
three jurisdictions in the world to
recognize our freedom and independence
we helped return the favor in the 1940s
and we have always been allies never
enemies even though we occasionally do
go around and around with each other no
to NATO one year yes to NATO in another
year no to Libya under one French
president come on let's go to Libya
under another French president when the
Philosopher's virus devastated Bordeaux
the vineyards were replanted with
American rootstock Chicago once banned
fraga from its restaurants I think it
made it a crime punishable by a fine by
contrast France in 2005 the problem at
designated foie gras as something worthy
of protection as part of French's
Frances a cultural heritage there's a
love/hate relationship frankly with
American rock music Hollywood movies and
fast food and just let me say on a
personal note I side with France on all
three of those we we have been fractious
friends but always friends and I
actually I don't see that changing and
friends want and need to understand each
other sharing our languages only helps
in that regard point number two life is
about beauty I work with economists most
days and hear a lot about cost-benefit
analyses utility functions Pareto
optimality and of course the
ever-present a policy mantra the
zero-sum game so this evening I could
approach why French matters from that
perspective to argue why it matters more
than say learning arabic or farsi or
mandarin or spanish but in my view
that's basically an endless argument
there's no clear answer we can go on and
on forever in a relatively unproductive
x
sighs of course we need young people who
know foreign languages can locate
countries on a globe and hopefully know
something about those countries and as I
said most business leaders who run that
global companies will tell you that the
their employees who are exposed to
foreign cultures foreign languages have
a competitive advantage over those who
don't and yes we do need expertise in
certain critical languages such as
Arabic Farsi and Mandarin but the debate
should be about addition and not
subtraction education is about growing
it's not about zero some exercises life
is also not just about getting and
spending it's also about enjoying and
France is the greatest country in the
world where when it comes to enjoying
life in French there's a phrase las a la
mode and that is what the French have
done in so many areas in art literature
film photography fashion food and the
enjoyment of life the appreciation of
beauty and there is no doubt a reason
why utilitarianism began in the UK and
not in France point number three
Americans really want to be French in
France its landscape its language its
people in France we see a reflection of
ourselves as Americans and who we want
to be France in my view inspires and
shapes our imagination and our
aspirations I work in Washington DC just
below Dupont Circle Washington was
designed by a Frenchman pyaar hua the
capital is named after our first
president who's extremely close friend
and Ally was Lafayette I ride the myth
hope now bear with me on this this is
not meant to be offensive New York by
contrast thinks that it's Paris but
hasn't yet realized that it isn't Paris
and never will be Paris but it's okay
it's still fun to try new yorkers ride
the subway not the Metro in New York
time is money in para
time is to be lost and then found but
don't misunderstand me both cities are
great in their own ways but their
differences also matter New York is
energy Paris is beauty we want to be
Hemingway on the left bank we want to be
artistic Emma Grey's paint like Monet or
Picasso at least I do we want to be some
of the guys here we want to be that
fellow in the picture kissing the girl
at the end of the war suave and sushi on
insouciant debonair that special
attitude we want to sit where Sokka sat
at Lydda Mego helps the writing we go to
France to think and feel and be alive to
linger there is quite simply no other
country in the world with so much
diversity and variety in such a small
space let me turn to the fourth point
about the dance and why I find that
metaphor so important now this is not
about solar Pont d'Avignon although it
could be when I when I think of why
French matters I am drawn to to
novelists one French one english and one
French painter the writers are mad post
and Anthony pole and the painter is
Nicolas Nicolas Poussin now I am
hesitant to say anything at all this
evening about boost with Antoine
companion companion in the audience and
so I hope that you will be tolerant of
my efforts here at what you called
cutting and pasting pusa Proust and pole
worked in different mediums and at
different times but they reach out to us
in similar ways they tell us that life
is lyrical often circular filled with
movement grace and beauty that life is
often an unpredictable dance with
movements between time present time
passed and time future and yes I think
Prust influence TS Eliot who also wrote
in French and translated from the French
mixing memory and forgetfulness desire
and loss adding broken brushstrokes to a
canvas changing the picture planes
perspective
entering forever the way we experience
and perceive our world one of Poussin's
great paintings is called a dance to the
music of time in his monumental novel in
search of lost time Prust makes only a
few references to Pusan whom one of his
characters calls that old hack but there
are countless references to art painting
perspective else dear with will Whistler
I guess is the model for else dear i
think or is that i've been told but both
pusa and Prost inspired anthony polls
great 12 volume novel sequence known as
a dance to the music of time which is
occasionally referenced as well as the
one novel in English that comes closest
to proofs incomparable accomplishment
this relationship between pusa prust and
pol is itself a dance between artists
and styles and times and perspectives we
are enriched in whatever ways we can
experience these writers even if we can
only read them in French or English
translations now let me permit me if you
would to close on a very personal note
the best job I ever had was during the
three summers 1971 through 73 when I
worked as a stodgy air with the kiddie
Leone a bank in can I earned I earned
$65 a week you try living in can on that
budget my job was in the bank's foreign
exchange office where I waited on
customers and did currency exchange
transactions which at the time generated
what seemed to me to be an enormous
volume of totally useless bureaucratic
paper a copy for the client a copy for
the can branch one for the nice regional
bank and a copy for Lucia Chantal Apache
whenever I completed one of these
transactions Frank's into Deutsche marks
or lira into Frank's whatever I was
instructed to follow a long tradition of
placing the converted currency pinned to
yet another copy of the receipt in an
old cigar box that's
that on a corner of my boss's desk I
learned that the cigar box have actually
been on that desk since 1945 when
American forces had used the bank as a
quartermaster as a quartermaster's
office to pay the troops when one
afternoon my boss who is a native ken
wha who remains a very close friend
nearly 40 years later said to me shall
via Shiva the multi nose out sheave come
I want to show you the bank's archives
so he took me down a very narrow
staircase into the dim barely lit
basement of all who don t and there I
saw countless shelves as far as I could
see I mean ruin three or four times the
size of where we are now at least three
or four times the size countless shells
filled to overflowing with endless and
totally useless musty old receipts from
tens of thousands of transactions
stretching over many decades it was
totally ludicrous and i am sure or i
hope that these receipts have all
vanished by now and then my friend said
to me words i have never forgotten he
said you know sometimes after work a few
of us come down here we bring some
lights and we danced this is why French
matters to me
you